- Thanks to Ron DeSantis,
the immigrants that he sent
to Martha's Vineyard
may be staying in the US for good.
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
made headlines for chartering a flight
from Texas to Massachusetts
in order to dump 50 asylum seekers
in Martha's Vineyard
as a political stunt.
This may all have backfired
because the Bexar County Sheriff,
Javier Salazar, said that
the DeSantis migrants
were victims of a crime.
People who are crime victims
or witnesses to a crime
are eligible for
something called a U Visa,
which allows them to remain in the US.
Congress created the U Visa
with the passage of the victims
of Trafficking and
Violence Protection Act.
Immigrants who are willing
to help law enforcement authorities
in the investigation or prosecution
of the criminal activity
could eventually get a green card.
He signed the certification forms
for all the migrants
saying that they were transported
under false pretenses,
which is the crime
of unlawful restraint.
Under Texas Penal Code Section 20.02,
a person commits an offense
if he intentionally or knowingly
restrains another person.
Unlawful restraint can be
a Class A Misdemeanor,
state jail felony,
or third degree felony
depending on the nature of the offense.
So way to go, Ron.